we're delighted to bring you this
seminar presented by lab roots and in
collaboration with the National
Institute of Health welcome to our track
on the NIH brain initiative a
multidisciplinary approach to
neuroscience we're glad you can join us
for today's panel presentation titled
cracking and neural circuits function
through high resolution physiology
connectomics and computational modeling
it's my pleasure to introduce a panel of
experts who will be speaking on the
topic of advancing human neuroscience
for a full listing please click on the
tab at the top of your screen if any
questions arise during the presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the
Q&A box our speakers respond back to you
via email as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits tab
located at the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming our panel of
experts thank you for joining us my name
is Imran oxide a few things become
abundantly clear when we look at these
beautiful drawings from ramona qahal of
Golgi stain neurons in the brain one
call is a master obviously - the brain
is extremely beautiful three neurons and
the networks in which they are embedded
are frighteningly complex one of the
Grand Challenges today I think is to
understand this complexity understanding
this complex complexity is important not
only for our ability to be able to
better treat diseases like epilepsy or
Alzheimer's but also to make advances in
artificial intelligence where artificial
neural networks are inspired or derived
from our understanding of biological
networks networks or our exploration of
neuroscience now has a number of tools
available to it on the physiology side
we can use auto physiology opto
physiology can use quantitative
behavioral analyses
a variety of anatomical tools and a
range of computational modeling tools
however each one of these tools by
itself only looks at a facet of the
complexity of the nervous system our
approach has been to treat these tools
as complementary and to try to apply the
tools and as much as possible the same
setting so that the results from the
efforts with one tool can be quickly
translated to the results and compared
with the results of efforts with another
tool this tightly coupled approach of
course requires a tightly coupled and
integrated team my laboratory focuses on
physiology and behavior large-scale
imaging targeted perturbations our
efforts in laboratory for this project
and what we're going to present today
has been contributed primarily by Alex
Ramirez Sebastian Seung's laboratory
uses the tools of serial section
electron microscopy and connect omics
and we're joined today by one of the
principal individuals in his laboratory
who has led that work Ashwin Vishwanatha
mark Coleman's laboratory focuses on
computational models and network
inferencing and we'll hear today from
Mark about a lot of the work that Alex
Sood has done the plan for today is that
first mark will provide an overview of
the questions that were most interested
in and a theoretical background and the
theoretical underpinnings of our
experimental efforts i will then build
off of some of the predictions and
background that he gave and give you
recent results on the physiology and
large-scale imaging that we've been able
to accomplish in the zebrafish that will
feed directly into the efforts of the
CERN laboratory that will be presented
on connectomics links between various
neurons and within
populations and then Mark Coleman will
come back and incorporate these data
into the models that were introduced
generating new predictions
I will then summarize and the end with a
few words Marco Luque so the core
scientific question we're going to be
addressing today is how did neural
circuits hold on to a short-term memory
to motivate this I want to show an
experiment from Renault fo Roma's lab on
delay activity in the prefrontal cortex
in this experiment a monkey had a
vibration of a given frequency applied
to its fingertip there was then a delay
period during which it needed to
remember the frequency of this stimulus
because after the delay period the
monkey was presented a second vibration
to its fingertip and it needed to say
whether the second vibration frequency
was higher or lower in frequency than
the first vibration during these
experiments they recorded from the
prefrontal cortex and I'm showing you
this activity here so shown in red is
the trace of one neuron recording the
prefrontal cortex the white dots on the
top of the graph are individual raster's
from many different trials of individual
neuronal firing the red trace is showing
the average of that smooth out and what
you see is that during the delay period
there is this persistent neural activity
which we believe is holding on to a
memory of the vibration frequency
applied to the finger chip before times
zero the reason that we think this
persistent activity is encoding for the
vibration frequency is because when they
record following different frequencies
of vibration applied to the fingertip
that's shown here so for this neuron
that was recorded following a low
frequency vibration applied to the
fingertip there was a low sustained
firing rate and following a high
frequency vibration applied to the
fingertip there was a high frequency of
firing a high rate of firing and you can
see the traces in between where for
intermediate vibration frequencies that
had to be remembered again so that they
could be compared to the
and stimulus so this example actually
illustrates the type of activity we'll
be looking at and the Roma group and
collaboration with Christian Machens and
Carlos Brody also built a model for this
which i think is illustrative of the
history of the field and the basic
conceptual idea for what we think is the
mechanism for maintaining such
persistent activity the key idea is that
when a brief command like the vibration
to the fingertip is applied and applied
it causes currents to flow into a neuron
but a typical neuron in isolation its
firing that would go up in response to
such an input but then it would come
down quickly on some neuronal or
synaptic timescale which is typically of
order hundreds of milliseconds or less
as opposed to the six second delay
period that you saw in the task but of
course we know that neurons are not in
isolation they're part of networks and
the basic theory of how this persistent
activity is maintained is that when a
command input comes into a neuron as
looking at the neuron on the Left it
begins firing but then that neuron can
convey convey signals to its neighbors
and receive feedback from those
neighbors through positive feedback
pathways these positive feedback
pathways can be in two forms there can
be recurrent excitation where the
neurons that were initially activated
activate themselves and other similarly
tuned neurons and there also can be a
double negative form of positive
feedback where the neuron pool on the
Left inhibits the neuron pool on the
right which had previously been
inhibiting them therefore causing a
double negative form of disinhibition
and again allowing persistent activity
to be maintained and is shown in the
bottom trace is a neuron receiving such
Network positive feedback when a prep
really tune can maintain persistent
activity for a long duration much longer
than the time constant of an individual
neuron or sent ups so that's a
motivating example we're going to
actually show you work in a related
system in terms of storing a short term
memory but it's another type it's a
different type of analog memory system
and it's known as a neural integrator so
just to review from calculus when I say
integration I mean integration in the
sense of calculus so shown
the top of this graph is an input stream
shown in red and then this goes through
an integration and then the output shown
in the bottom is the integral of this
input and a reminder that an integral
from calculus is just a running total or
a sum sometimes just called an
accumulator in the cycle lot in the
psychology literature so when you see
this first brief pulse of input go in
the integrator accumulates that and then
and then at the next time time period
there is no input so accumulating
nothing is staying still another input
comes in it accumulates that then
there's nothing coming in so it stays
still and so on and so forth and the
accumulation can be a positive inputs or
negative which would correspond to
inhibitory inputs as shown at the end so
the key focus that we want to have today
is that in the absence of input an
accumulator holds on to its running
total that is it holds a memory of the
running total of its past inputs so
integrators have been found to be
encrypt incredibly prevalent in the
brain underlying many different types of
core behaviors in decision-making we
believe that the core process of the
decision-making is to accumulate noisy
evidence over time we see evidence of
this an individual neuron recordings and
then the idea is that a decision is made
when this accumulated evidence reaches a
threshold likewise in navigation one of
the key determinants of our position in
the world is believed to be the
integration of velocity signals
indicating our movement through the
world for the rest of the talk we're
going to focus on a particular
integration in the brain in the motor
system and it's going in an area of the
brain known as the oculomotor neural
integrator and I'm going to show you a
video of this activity here in the video
what you will see is the movement of the
goldfish's eyes the camera will zoom in
and you will see that when there is no
visual stimulus for the for the fish to
track and its head is still you'll see
that it moves in a period in a sequence
of cicadas and fixations cicadas are
rapid eye movements that move the eyes
between one place and another
and the fixations are just when the eye
is held still video please
okay so in the video I just showed you
you saw the animals eyes moving back and
forth this is a cartoon of the
oculomotor neural integrator system for
the control of eye position on the
bottom is shown an eye trace
corresponding to what you just saw the
fish holds its eyes at one position then
there's a rapid saccade to a neighboring
position that's held then a rapid
saccade again and so on and so forth
these the Cod's are created by high
velocity coding command neurons which
have brief bursts of firing in this
cartoon I have just indicated in a
positive direction excited the output of
excitatory burst neurons which move the
eyes one direction and indicated with a
negative pulse the output of inhibitory
pathways which move the eyes the other
direction what I'd like to focus on here
is that in order to maintain the eyes
which have spring-like muscles there
needs to be a constant force in the
absence of any signal that is to say
when there is no bursts input when
there's no eye velocity command in order
to maintain the eyes at a given position
there needs to be some persistent
driving signal generated from the
nervous system and it was identified
many years ago that this is carried by
an area of the brain known as the
oculomotor integrator neurons and I'm
showing a recording of one of these
neurons here in the middle panel and
what I'd like you to notice is that
every time an input comes in the firing
rate is mathematically integrating that
is accumulating that signal to me to
then go up to a higher persistent level
of activity so again persistent activity
in this system can be maintained an
analog set of levels corresponding to
the analog range of AI positions that
can be maintained and it's storing the
running total of the eye velocity input
commands now for the rest of the talk I
won't show you the firing rate traces
but I'll rather show you tuning curves
where we plot for any given I fix
station the firing rate of a neuron as a
function of I position so for an example
neuron each of the dots here corresponds
to one i fixation and you can see that
the firing rate is very linear as a
function of sustained eye position and I
should note that all of the recordings
shown are done in the
dark so this activity is generated
without visual feedback so it needs to
be that the activity is internally
generated okay so this is showing you
one tuning curve of one neuron but in
fact there's a whole population of
neurons and there's a beautiful
organization in the fish oculomotor
system where the right side neurons are
like the ones I showed you that is the
firing rates increases the eyes move
from left to right and then on the
opposite side of the brain on the left
side the firing rates decrease from left
to right statistically the firing rates
are equivalent here I have literally
just done a mirror image of the right
side neurons and we've done a mirror
image of them to show the left side
neurons but really they're statistically
the same there's also we think from
gross anatomy a beautiful organization
of these cells so the cells are arranged
on either side of the brain on either
side of the midline there is an
excitatory and inhibitory population on
either side the end the interesting
thing about these is they have exactly
the connections one would expect from
the theory of positive feedback leading
to persistent activity that is to say on
any given side of the brain there are
recurrent excitatory connections that
are the ones that we think could
maintain excitatory positive feedback in
between the two sides of the brain there
are recurrent inhibitory connections
those shown in blue here and that means
that one side of the brain can inhibit
the side of the brain that was
previously inhibiting it again forming a
double negative form of positive
feedback pathway so given these this
gross organization of the anatomy and
given the known physiology at the time
this was done in the goldfish we'll move
forward to showing you our more recent
work in the zebrafish we built a model
trying to understand exactly how this
type of persistent activity is generated
and particular try to understand rate
predictions for what the microstructure
of this architecture is as well as
understanding the core macro structure
in other words is it the recurrent
excitation which is the primary driver
of the persistent activity or is it the
recurrent disinhibition and I'll say
that the history of the field had
proposed for theoretical reasons that it
was disinhibition but I'm going to show
you that in fact we believe is two
recurrent excitation within one side of
the brain which is the answer in
system so our model is sketched out here
so in the upper right you see just a
caricature of the model with again the
four populations of neurons that I
showed you there are about a hundred
neurons in this brain region
there's about we made 25 neurons per
population and the key thing that we
wanted to model was the firing dynamics
of each neuron that is how does a firing
rate change over time dr/dt and each of
these terms corresponds to one
contribution of that
so there are intrinsic properties of the
cells court characterized by the
intrinsic leak that's minus F of r and
then what's offsetting is intrinsic link
and driving the cells is same side
excitation we model that as a weighted
sum with weight W IJ going through a
synapse which can have a non-linearity s
of the input R that is an input R is
driving an input arch from neuron J is
driving the output of neuron I through
first to synaptic non-linearity and then
an overall strength of that connection
and we sum that up for all inputs
likewise that we send that from the
anatomy there is inhibition coming from
the uppers from the opposite side which
we model in the same way there is also
tonic background inputs coming in to
these and the burst commands represents
those Socata commands which move the
eyes from one place to another so the
question is how out of a set of
equations like this can one get an
integrator and I and in particular how
can one maintain persistent activity in
the absence of reverse command that is
when the burst command is zero we want
to have persistent activity persistent
activity would correspond to dr/dt
equals zero no change over time in the
firing rate and that occurs when all of
these terms up to the burst command must
sum to zero when they sum to zero dr/dt
equals zero there's persistent activity
in the absence of the burst command but
what I'd like you to notice is if these
terms all sum to zero then we have that
the derivative of the firing rate is
proportional to the burst command and if
we have that the derivative of the
firing rate is proportional the burst
command then from calculus we have that
the firing rate is proportional to the
integral of the burst command so we
fundamentally think that this is how
integrators are kriya
in the brain that is to say that
integrators are created when there is a
balance of excitatory inhibitory in
recurrent chronic recurrent inputs and
off that sorry recurrent inputs that
offset the intrinsic leak and therefore
allow persistent activity to be
maintained and burst commands to be
integrated so we set out to be to fit
this model to data from the goldfish we
actually built a conductance based model
that was fit by a cost function approach
and the cost function I won't go through
the details but it had different terms
in it which penalized different errors
in modeling different aspects of the
experiments so we have intracellular
current injection experiments that I
will not show the database of single
neuron tuning curves that I showed you
and firing rate drift patterns following
focal lesions and we wanted to bring all
these together within one modeling
framework to be clear the knowns in this
framework are the recorded firing rates
and the intrinsic responses f of R from
the single neuron current injection
experiments the unknowns as in many
systems are the synaptic weights and the
external inputs also unknown is the
exact form of the synaptic or dendritic
nonlinearities at excitatory and s
inhibitory and I refer you to our paper
from 2013 to see the details of the
fitting method what I want to show you
here is just that the fitting method
works so this is actually showing you on
the top an example model in there on
voltage trace from the full conductance
base model you can see a psychotic input
coming in with a brief pulse that drives
an immediate change in firing rate of
the neuron but then importantly what I
want you to notice is before that first
akattak pulse the firing rate was zero
after the pulse you can see the
persistent activity a second pulse comes
in and following that second pulse it
has been integrated because there is a
higher rate of persistent activity we
then just plotted the firing rates of
neurons like this like this one it's
actually I'm showing you a different
neuron and that's shown in the lower
left and the lower left you see firing
rate as a function of time gray was the
raw firing rate in the model black is
what you would see in most experimental
papers where we've run this through a
smoothing filter just to make it clear
what the pattern is and green is just
highlighting a perfect integral so the
MA
is perfectly integrating the external
inputs we could actually do this and
nearly perfectly fit the tuning curve of
every single neuron in our database of
recordings and that's shown in the lower
lower right so the lines in this case
are the tuning curves from the data that
I showed you the boxes are at each
individual I position that the simulated
I went to what the firing rate was plus
the noise because we also tried to model
the variability in this system which is
a different story I will not talk about
today
okay so I want to now step to what
insights did we get from this modeling
exercise and the insights came most
strongly from the following experiment
and it was the inactivation experiment
so in this set of experiments which came
from which were done by Emery oxide and
David tanks lab they inactivated the
left side of the integrator while
recording neurons on the right side of
the integrator and what you see on the
right side of the slide is the drift
firing pattern caused by this now I want
to remind you that the connections
between the two sides of the circuit are
mediated by inhibition so we said that
to maintain persistent activity there
needed to be a balance of excitation net
excitation offsetting the intrinsic leak
so if there was a balance of inputs
allowing persistent activity removing
the inhibition coming from the
contralateral side of the circuit onto a
given neuron we would expect to make the
firing rates drift upwards because now
they have bent their inputs are
imbalanced by having a lot lack of
inhibition so we expect again the find
rates to increase and that's exactly
what we saw at low firing rates however
puzzlingly at high firing rates you can
see that the activity maintained its
persistence and that was not to be
expected because again we expected to
have a loss of inhibitory in a removal
of inhibitory input and therefore we
expected to have a firing rate drift
upwards at all possible firing rates
well we found that we could reproduce
this in the model which is being shown
here below under certain conditions so
we found that we basically reason that
when the neurons on the right side of
the circuit are at high firing rates
recall the tuning curves that right side
neurons increase their firing rates as
the eyes move from left to right left
side neurons decrease their firing rates
as the eyes move from left to right
therefore when a right side neuron is at
high firing rates that means the left
side neurons in a fully intact circuit
would have been at low firing rates so
these high firing rates occur when the
inactivated side would be at low
firing rates however there still would
be firing rates and there still would be
activity so what the modeling suggested
is that such low rates are below a
threshold for contributing that is
removing low rate firing is not
sufficient to disrupt the persistent
activity and there are many biophysical
mechanisms that we considered for this
for example a strong presynaptic
facilitation could contribute
postsynaptically something like an NMDA
channel which is known to be prevalent
in this circuit may need to be present
in order to cause a NMDA spike and again
that would have a threshold so there are
many biophysical processes but for this
talk what I really want to emphasize is
that the low rates appear to be below a
threshold for contributing and that
allows stable firing act of activity at
high frame or firing rates then
importantly what this says is that each
side of the integrator independently can
maintain persistent activity on its own
at high firing rates what we think the
inhibition does is coordinates the two
sides so that really the high firing
rate side is the driver of activity and
then that is just holding the other
sides at its low firing rates and really
the the low fine right side is the
follower I now I wanted to step back and
put this all together and say what does
this imply about the question that I
open with is it recurrent excitation or
recurrent inhibition which maintains
persistent activity in this system so
consider as shown here network activity
when the eyes are directed rightward
when the eyes are directed rightward
what we just said is the right side
neurons are at high firing rate and
above threshold for transmitting to
their neighbors so this means that for
example the right side recurrent
excitatory loop would be press
and that would be a form of positive
feedback contributing to persistent
activity but now consider those left
side neurons those left side neurons we
just argued are below threshold for
contributing therefore even though
anatomically they are there is a
projection from the left of the right
side we believe that when the eyes are
directed rightward as highlighted by
these dashed lines the functional
connectivity is such that there is no
connectivity going from the left to the
right again the left side is at low
rates that we believe are below
threshold that means there is no mutual
inhibitory feedback loop between the two
sides at any given point in time and
therefore we believe that in a decent
abyssion or the double negative
potential form of positive feedback loop
is not present so the conclusion is that
excitation not inhibition maintains
persistent activity and inhibition is
anatomically recurrent but functionally
forward visa is functionally
feed-forward and this is actually going
to guide some of our future experiments
the other thing I want to point out is
this picture right here is just a gross
reduction of the circuit to just four
populations as for lump sums but we
wanted to understand what about the rich
micro circuitry within each of these
populations and when we want to do that
we realized there was a potential
problem and the potential problem is
that there are about a hundred neurons
in this circuit and therefore there are
about 10 100 times 100 or 10,000
potential synaptic connections so that
means in terms of modeling there's going
to be a greatly over specified model
what we call a non identifiability
problem so we wanted to be able to say
well what features of the connectivity
are important and what features the
connectivity are not important and can
we formally say something about that
from the experiments that have been
conducted so what we did is we did a
sensitivity analysis to determine which
features of the connectivity are most
critical and the idea is our model I
mentioned was built through a cost
function and this is just showing a
cartoon cost function showing potential
to the model cost function surface for
two hypothetical parameters in this case
the green direction if that parameter of
the model which you could think of is
something like a synaptic weight was
changed that caused a great error in the
model fit there is a strong curvature on
the other hand in the red direction that
is a direction which is insensitive if
that parameter of the model has changed
almost nothing happens in the cost
function and that one is insensitive and
could be tuned at many different values
and still lead to the same approximately
the same model performance the way we
capture such curvature in a cost
function is through the hessian matrix
of second derivatives v squared cost v
wi DW j where each of those w's is one
of the individual weight parameters of
which there are 5000 potential
connections 10000 up to restrictions of
neurons having to go to one side which
reduces that by 2 what you can do to
find out what the important sensitive
directions are is do a principal
components analysis of this matrix that
is find the eigenvectors so an eigen
vector of this Hessian matrix identifies
the patterns of weight changes to which
the system is most sensitive the most
sensitive ones are the ones with the
largest eigen values which corresponds
from the strongest curvature and when we
did this surprisingly we found that
there were only four most sensitive
components that a per neuron so for the
fits to any given neuron and the fits
and the components I should say were
quite similar across the neurons so
essentially what this is saying is there
are really only four combinations of
weights not individual age but four
combinations or patterns of weights that
were really important to maintain the
tuning of this circuit and be able to
reproduce the experimental data and
that's highlighted in the next slide I'm
going to go through this briefly but
briefly speaking here is showing some of
the sensitive sensitive directions and
what is being shown in the top row here
so take the top left it's the first
principal component what this says is
positive is making connections more or
more excitatory or less inhibitory so
the numbers 1 through 50 on the bottom
is describing for one postsynaptic
neuron it has 50 pre synaptic inputs 25
of those are excitatory 25 are
inhibitory and what's being done in this
principal component is raised is
increasing the excitatory connections
and decreasing or removing in addition
from the inhibitory connection strengths
and you can see below this if you
perturb that direction by making this
change in the weights it causes the fine
race to run off to a saturation level
the second most important component was
what happens if one decreases excitation
and then also decreases inhibition that
led to what we can call a leaky
integrator where you can see all of the
activities below look like they are
exponentially decaying to a single
steady state and then there were two
components components three and four
which related to the specific thresholds
of the neurons high threshold neurons
versus low threshold neurons low
threshold neurons firing throughout the
eye position range high threshold ones
ones that recruited only only through
part only were recruit is the eyes move
from left to right after the eyes and
move through part of the range and in
that case there were distinct patterns
that if you perturb those disrupted
those patterns that also led to drift
patterns like the one you see below what
I'd really like to highlight for you is
on the right this is the tenth most
important component out of the 50
components and you can see that clusters
of excitatory and clusters of inhibitory
connections were either turned up or
turned down nevertheless perturbing but
exactly the same magnitude vector
magnitude as the other perturbations I'm
showing you led to almost no change in
the persistent activity and that seemed
below why is that well ultimately that's
because there are offsetting effects so
if you think of a given neuron what
we've done is we've effectively turned
up excitatory input and turn up
inhibitory input in a way that those
cancel or maybe turned up some
excitatory inputs and turn down other
excitatory inputs and again a way that
those cancel and when you think about
these insensitive components it has a
tremendous implication for how we think
about circuits and what we really can
conclude from any given circuit model
often in modeling we like to put out our
best fit our maximum likelihood model
and I wanted to show you what do we
think maybe is is you know a real issue
for doing that and maybe how we instead
should think about what the important
sensitive directions are and really
distinguished let those be what's
important and just
English that from directions that are
insensitive and this you know whole
framework we think really lets you say
what was important what isn't important
and this slide here really emphasizes
what isn't important so what I've laid
out here is the connectome you know in
our model neuron this is again a hundred
neurons they're organized in groups the
red connections are the excitatory
populations the blue are the inhibitory
populations the first 50 neurons are on
the left side of the brain the second 50
neurons on the right side of the brain
so for example the upper left block
would be talking about left side neurons
connecting recurrently to each other and
the examples connect them I show you on
the left it is statistically something
like all the all connectivity there's a
little you know there are some details
in there but basically everything is
connecting to everything by contrast
look at the circuit on the right in this
case this is a circuit with very local
connectivity and here we actually assign
anatomical locations to each neuron in
anticipation of the zebrafish
experiments that you'll see momentarily
and here this one you can see that the
connectivity is clustered around the
diagonal of each block for excitation so
that corresponds to look spatially local
recurrent connectivity now I want to
show you the responses of neurons on the
bottom so what I'm showing you here is
actually just a pooled responses summing
up all the right side neurons in black
or summing up all the left side neurons
in gray but it actually holds for
individual neurons as well and again in
both networks it integrates the pink and
orange traces are just indicating a
perfect integral and I would challenge
you in a psycho physics experiment to be
able to distinguish between these two
literally every nook and cranny of these
traces is essentially identical and that
says that fundamentally here are two
extremely different network
architectures leading to nearly
identical performance how can we explain
some data like this and what's going on
in the model and the way we explain it
as we go back to thinking of our
sensitive and are insensitive directions
so what we do it did is we actually took
the difference between the
connectivities we took the connectivity
on the Left subtracted it subtracted the
connectivity in the right and then
the differences between the two
connectivities along the sensitive
insensitive eigenvector directions and
that's shown here so this is showing the
difference between the circuits along
each components so what you'll notice is
that recall that there were only four
sensitive directions that were important
for determining the function in the
output of this circuit and matching the
experiments and these first four
components that were important between
these two circuits that I'm showing
their difference is exponentially small
note that the y-axis in this graph is
logarithmic that means that the
difference between these two circuits is
someplace between e to the minus 8 and e
to the minus 10 in difference that is
these are virtually identical in terms
of what's important for determining the
function of the circuit the other
components that are more different
between them and lead to the visual
differences in the Topman the
topographic differences are along the
insensitive directions the other thing
that I want to point out is this says
that we need to clearly dive in and do
more experiments if we really want to
understand how this circuit works we now
have two very very different
architectures and nearly all - all
connected Network on the left and a very
locally modularly connected network on
the right so to summarize our lessons
learn from this part of the talk first
in terms of the gross anatomy and the
gross structure of this architecture
what we have shown is that recurrent
excitation we is what we believe
generates persistent act firing and the
recurrent inhibition is used to
coordinate the two sides that can
generate their persistent activity
independently but if we want to
understand just what generates the
persistent activity we really only need
to understand one half of the network
and we can look at one half the network
in isolation because we know it
generates persistent activity on its own
that is a motivation for some of the
experiments that we'll follow the second
key conclusion from this part of the
talk is that we clearly need much richer
anatomical information to understand
truly what patterns of excitation
underlie the persistent fun thank you
mark I think very nicely summarizes a
long series of experimental work that
allowed us to develop
by a physically realistic and rich model
of the system which then has led to
predictions that really now forces us
experimentally to take things to another
level and to go to a high throughput
strategy where we can look at the
activity of many cells and the
connectivity of many cells really in one
brain at one time to do this what we
have done is to transition to the larval
zebrafish preparation where the small
size of the animal the robust behavior
of the animal in combination with tools
like two-photon microscopy as shown on
the Left have allowed us now to look at
large-scale at mini neurons at high
resolution so on the video we're gonna
see at the right we're gonna show you
multiple planes taken through the
zebrafish brain in the live animal the
green channel will show the nuclear
localized G cam signal which is a
calcium sensor a fast calcium sensor
that serves as a good proxy for the
firing rate activity of with a
particular cell and you're also going to
have on the red channel an indication of
where the excitatory neuron the Goethe
motoric neurons are located so with this
now exquisite resolution and spatial
coverage of large regions of the brain
we can build beautiful dynamical maps of
the activity throughout the oculomotor
circuit during a behavior in this video
we're going to see now we're going to
look at the activity projected across
the brain onto the horizontal plane at
top and then onto the sagittal plane
from all the neurons on the left and all
the neurons on the right as the eye
position is transitioning from one
location to the other and I'll get into
the details of what individual neurons
are doing next but this is simply to
illustrate the power of this approach
along the broad distribution of activity
profiles that you saw there one of the
major classes were these neurons that
show a step like change in activity or
firing rate as the eyes move from one
position to another of course a large
contribution to that population comes
from the integrator neurons there are
also neurons associated with the motor
system that we'll talk about in a second
the traces at the top show the raster's
associated with individual psychotic
events from single neuron as you move
from the right to the left and in the
second row second box we're looking at
movements from the left to the right the
rapid transitions at time zero then are
somewhat filtered due to the dynamics of
the calcium buffering within the system
but we know from simultaneous recordings
with firing rates that these transitions
are accurately reflecting the underlying
changes changes in the action potentials
next slide in the next slide then we see
another type of activity that's
prevalent within this population or in
this oculomotor region and those are the
neurons associated with psychotic events
and they show a burst response very
transient and very sharp at each
individual psychotic event and through
this exploratory process we have also
discovered novel cells that we have not
expected for example these neurons that
show a long ramp in activity ahead of a
saccade and we know from work that alex
ramirez has done that these are involved
and the planning of the next psychotic
event itself
by doing this large-scale approach we
are now able to look at where these
different activity associated neuron
behaviorally associated neurons where
they're located and that allows us then
to start to specify the functional
identity in the oculomotor circuit which
allows it annotations that inform then
they connect homeless work that we're
going to see next so in this video what
you're going to look at is the locations
of cells that are increasing their
firing rates with every movement to the
left and increasing and maintaining the
activity throughout the leftward
fixation with some of the neurons that
we see in that three-dimensional map
we're able to identify simply based on
the locations so for example the neurons
that are at the right side of this image
this particular claim taken fairly
ventral in the zebrafish brain our cells
that are residing within the inferior
olive which is easily identified through
its location other populations like the
abducens motor neurons can be identified
through registration between the
functionally imaged brain and brains
where neurons associated with different
transgenic lines have been identified
and where previous work has specified
what type of role that neuron plays so
here we can look at the mmx1 GFP line
where motor neurons have been identified
where we can see also the nerve that
presents to the lateral rectus muscle
that controls the eyes themselves and so
the overlap that you're seeing in the
lower portion of the brain suggests to
us that the neurons associated with
leftward activity and
overlap with the teal signal of the cyan
signal are in fact the motor neurons
themselves other regions of the brain
have not as well been as characterized
as well those populations then we need
to take a combined approach where we
look at first some single cell structure
function information where we label
neurons that show a particular pattern
of activity with dyes that allow us to
see where their axons project to and so
what you're looking at on the right are
a population of six neurons that have
been individually labeled and we can see
their axons projecting to the abducens
and these have now the appropriate
anatomical projection patterns that we
would expect of a pre motor neuron class
that is involved in integration we can
also now register this these maps with
maps that have previously determined
where different excitatory or inhibitory
neuron classes are and we can specify
which of the neurons that have the
fixation signal are GABAergic which are
glutamatergic etc we can also do
targeted appellation experiments here
ablating some of the cells within the
rung mere 7 8 caudal portions of the
hind brain and showing that as expected
for deficits in a neural integrator the
eye movements following ablation are
quite a bit more leaky or drifting
towards a neutral position than in the
second situation in the control case in
the upper before case we can also do
transient perturbation experiments here
using a fiber optic stimulate a low or
dhalsim and a fraction of the cells
within the Rumney r78 fixation zone and
here now we see the expected
deflection and I position sustained a
deflection following a transient
suppression of activity within the
fixation neuron complex or what we think
is the integrator neuron complex with
him on year seven eight these combined
strategies have allowed us to now
identify throughout the oculomotor
circuit a number of the key elements a
number of the key players including the
psychotic person ions the motor neurons
the sticker the neurons cerebellar
granule cells inferior all of us I
showed you we've also been able to build
maps of the projections between one
group of neurons and another and uh
outlines for us in broad terms the
oculomotor circuit however we need to
move beyond these broad outlines to
answer the kinds of questions that mark
was raised and for that we can now use
the annotation that's been done it's a
couple with a connectomics effort that's
spearheaded by the work of Sebastian son
hi I'm Sebastian so and we promised I'm
going to tell you a little bit or at
least introduce to you the idea of using
connectfx to constrain models of neural
network function so as Mark showed you
it is beautiful modeling work his models
make a number of predictions about both
neural activity and the connectivity of
the network for a long time it's been
very difficult to get very precise
information about connections between
individual neurons but luckily the
technologies of connectomics have
they've come to the rescue
there's been a lot of progress in recent
years on methods of automated
acquisitions of Ian volumes
three-dimensional electron microscopy
volumes and there's also been progress
in applying deep learning and
crowdsourcing in order to create
reconsider
actions of the neural circuits that are
imaged in those volumes and in addition
it's been possible to combine electron
microscopy with calcium imaging so
senior scientist Ashwin Vishwanath on is
going to tell you about experiment in
which as larvae zebrafish that was
calcium image dendritic size lab that
those neurons those exact same neurons
were in is using electron microscopy and
be constructed to give us information
about circuitry so at this point I'll
hand it over to Ashwin he's going to
tell you the story of the circuits
involved in ocular motor function thank
you for that introduction Sebastian so
as Mark had pointed out previously we
would like to constrain some of the work
some of the models that his work has
generated and the gold standard for
doing something like this is electron
microscopy so with electron microscopy
you have the resolution that first you
know visualization of individual
synapses so you can not only reconstruct
the entire morphologies of neurons you
can also you construct and see the
puppeteer partners they're connected
partners and so to do this in an
automatic manner we use this contraption
that was developed in the lab of Jeff
Lichtman at Harvard essentially this
machine is like a conveyor belt which
collects sections that are being section
on acetyl on an ultramarathon so every
time the ultra microtome arm moves it
generates a new section and these
sections are picked up on this conveyor
belt now we can collect many such
sections and put it on a silicon wafer
and we can image them under the electron
microscope so to the left is the kind of
the overview of one such silicon wafer
where you can see small tiny dots and if
you zoom into each one of these small
small tiny dots you can see a sliver of
or an individual frame of
zebrafish and then from each one of
these low resolution images you can then
target the region of interest to be
acquired at high resolution and for the
purposes of this particular experiment
we targeted on one side of the brain and
this case it's the right side of the
brain has a market previously pointed
out we think that it's the recurrent
excitation on one side is largely
driving persistent activity so we chose
to restrict our volumes to one side of
the brain now we can acquire many
thousands and thousands of these
electron microscopic images we can
stitch all these images together and put
them together in a in a
three-dimensional volume and since this
animal was previously imaged on a
two-photon microscope for a calcium for
calcium indicator we can then correlate
the same cells for which we have calcium
imaging so we have function for these
cells from two-photon imaging and find
the same cells within the seed electron
microscopic volume so - the two images
that you see on the left one is from the
two-photon functional imaging and one
image is from the seal electron
microscope and the red arrows over here
are pointing to cell bodies for which we
actually have calcium imaging so we have
function and then we can locate the same
cell bodies in the CDM and reconstruct
them and also recover the morphology as
the same neurons so now it is not enough
just to reconstruct the neurons for
which we have functional imaging we'd
also like to reconstruct the who their
partners are and so historically this
effort has been kind of a very
time-consuming effort because
reconstructing you know some electron
microscopy is is extremely hard it's not
a task that can be undertaken by an
individual or maybe even a lab but would
need a lots of people in a large
community and so to do this we returned
to kind of automating this process and
we we leverage the tools coming out from
computer science world we use deep
learning or machine learning assisted
reconstructions so let me walk you
through what exactly this pipeline looks
like
so we use convolutional neural nets or
CNN's in this case and the pipeline
looks something like this we start off
with an image which is the raw image
over here on the raw image of the e/m we
then detect the boundaries for each one
of the new lights inside this image so
that's the middle image in the middle
and all the pixels within the boundaries
of one particular neuron are assigned to
a single object so each color over there
you see is a single object so now the
cartoon that the pictures that I'm
showing over here are all in two
dimensions but in reality this process
is happening in three dimensions so so
by doing this process essentially we're
reconstructing a large three-dimensional
objects each each of them new lights
that are belonging to individual neurons
now we can we can do a similar such
approach for even for detecting synaptic
junctions so synaptic junctions are
junctions where two neurons are
communicating to each other and a
classic hallmark of locating these
junctions are postsynaptic densities or
PS deeds so we we run another
convolutional neural net on images to
detect the PS T's and at each one of
these locations we can then also assign
who the presynaptic and postsynaptic
partner of these neurons are so by doing
this process we can not only reconstruct
thousands and thousands of neurons
within the e/m volume you can also then
reconstruct where all the synapses are
and you can also detect kind of the
edges between these neurons so in
essence you can you can think of this
like a large graph where each neuron is
a single node and you can and the
synapses are basically the the weights
and the edges between these nodes but
there is one problem with this approach
which is very often neural nets also do
end up making mistakes and the mistakes
typically happen in areas where maybe
there was an image defect or the image
acquisition was not perfect and so
typically that manifests the way that
manifests is for example if two objects
needed to be connected to each other to
form a large a single neuron and if
there was an image defect
then those two objects will be broken
apart or sometimes they would be merged
falsely so in essence we would like to
kind of validate or we would like to
proofread or the output of these deep
learning methods are providing us and
and to do this we turn to a crowdsource
platform this is a this is a
crowd-sourced effort developed in the
lab of Sebastian son called I wire
originally this was developed for
reconstructing neurons from a retina
database we have now repurposed this
website to validate neurons that are
coming out for just from a larval
zebrafish
so in essence so here's an image of the
landing page of this particular website
players can basically log in online and
look at completed neurons like in the
picture over here the balloon art and
you know that you see they can then
individually inspect each one of these
nubs of the neuron to either decide to
whether join more knobs to the existing
you're on or remove mums from the
existing you're on and they can do this
in an iterative manner and may and and
and this process is repeated over and
over again until we build a consensus as
to what the accurate representation of
the neuron is and so once that's been
done and experts look at it we then say
that this neuron is validated and then
we move on to the next neuron
so using this process we have now
reconstructed over 3,000 such neurons
from a larval zebrafish
right so so then we would like to so now
it's another armed with this we have now
about three thousand neurons like I said
we would like to be able to classify
these neurons so here's one example and
I'm gonna present the same example as
the abducens motor neurons that any ox I
spoke about previously so the abducens
motor neurons are motor neurons that
project to the eye muscle so that
directly involved in moving the eye so
from the e/m we can reconstruct cell
bodies we can reconstruct the dendrites
and the axons that are eventually going
to project to the modern humans we can
also see that there for they're located
roughly in the same area where we think
that should look at
[ __ ] in drama mears r5 and r6 so this
is one way of identifying neurons by
morphology so I'm calling this
structural identification another way of
identifying neurons is by their function
since we know that abuse since motor
neurons are directly involved in moving
the eye we know that they should also
have a functional signature of the eye
movement that they're gonna make in
essence if the animal was moving its eye
and the animal had calcium reporters in
there abuse motor neurons should also
report eye movement and that's exactly
what we see if you register all the
reconstructions to a standard atlas the
location where we see the abuse in
smaller neurons and the green dots for
example in the sagittal plane is exactly
the same location where we see calcium
signals for eye positions which is the
black dots so if you look at the two
coronal plans at each one of these
sagittal locations you see that the
locations of the cell bodies which is
the green circles overlaps very nicely
with where we see calcium imaging from
eye position sensitive neurons so these
are neurons that are active when the
animal is moving its eye and that's
exactly where we see the motor you know
so this gives us confidence both
structurally as well as functionally
that the neurons that we've classified
are in fact the abuse motor neurons so
this is just one example of a population
of neurons that we deconstructed but in
essence we've done this process for many
such populations and here is kind of a
summary of the many different
populations that we've reconstructed so
far we have we have reconstructed and
validated neurons that are belonging to
the vestibular class of neurons
so that's descending or Cavill neurons
and media local neurons we've
reconstructed axons from a psychotic
person Yunnan population as well as the
inhibitory neuron population and between
the neural integrator population as well
we've been able to kind of classify
these neurons based on their morphology
as well as their spatial location for
example we see integrator neurons
located in ROM Amir's four to six we
also see in
neurons in Ramah Mears 7 in a some of
them have axons that say in the same
side of the brain which is that a kind
excitation that mark and initials shown
in this model the blue the blue model
the the blue cartoon and then we also
have neurons that have axons that
project to the opposite side of the
brain that provided this inhibition
which was the dead card from that market
previously shown in the brain now we can
put all of this together from each of
the neurons from each one of these
classes together in a matrix or the
connectivity matrix the connectome such
that each row over here R is the is the
dendrite of a single neuron and each
column is the axon of the same unit and
each dot that you see is the normalized
number of synapses from that particular
axon to that particular neuron and so
you can see that you start you start
seeing some structure in this network
you see that the psychotic neurons are
projecting to the integrator neurons
which is in blue and they're also
projecting to the modern iran's you see
that the vestibular neurons also project
to integrate our neurons and the modern
yarns and then you also see the
integrator neurons that project onto
other integrator neurons as well as the
motor neurons so so as as was predicted
by the theory and and this has been a
kind of an open-ended question in the
field for a long time is positive
feedback truly a mode for excitation and
our results seem to validate that fact
we see a recurrent block just among the
if you if you follow the diagonal you
see that just a blue block which is the
integrators have this large recurrent
component another interesting feature
that we see from such a such a
connectivity matrix is this modular
organization so we see different modules
being created when you see the
feed-forward so from the integrators on
to the motor neurons you see some
integrators exclusively talk to motor
neurons whereas other integrator neurons
exclusively talk to inter nuclear
neurons so there's this modular
organization and then even within the
integrated recurrent block that red
block you see that if you follow the
diagonal you see that there is hints of
this modular organization like what Mark
had shown previously in one of his
one of his experimental graphs so so
that we have a fairly updated version of
what did we think the the the oculomotor
circuit looks like we've been able to
identify neurons in each one of these
key populations we also know the
connectivity amongst neurons in these
key populations and between neurons in
these key populations with arm so now
armed with this information in armed
with the connectivity matrix we can go
back and revisit some of the modeling
and plug this kind of this weight matrix
into the models and ask how exactly do
the models perform okay mark over to you
so thank you Ashwin
so given this connect ohmic information
we wanted to revisit our models recall
that our previous models really only
allowed us to draw very conclusions
about the growth structure of the
integrator but really didn't allow us to
first look at the microstructure of the
neural integrator and second our
previous models were only focused on the
neural integrator themselves and not on
the other associated regions of the
oculomotor hindbrain so what we asked to
start was what if we just take a simple
linear rate model this has some
reasonable justification that there are
linear tuning curves and linear firing
rates and high background firing rates
throughout the oculomotor system but
also now that we're trying to look an
expanded question we also just started
with a simplest model which is a linear
model and we took this linear model and
we said what if we just directly put in
the connectome as our weight matrix plus
known signs of the connections from the
physiology would that alone be able to
reproduce the measured sensitivities to
AI position of the oculomotor integrate
of the oculomotor hindbrain neurons and
remarkably I'm going to show you that it
did so this is showing you what came out
of the model and what you'll notice is
across these four prominent populations
that showed up in the connectome in
which we analyzed you see that different
neurons have different tuning curve
relationships firing rate from versus
eye position so in particular the
integrator neurons are shown in dark
yellow
and those are the ones we talked about
before we found that just from the raw
connectome that the abducens motor
neurons and the abducens inner nuclear
neurons should have more sensitivity to
eye position and we found that the
vestibular neurons should have nearly
zero sensitivity to eye position so we
then after doing this went back and
looked at the literature both in the
fish and across different species and
here's what we found so I should say
just for truth in explaining this that
we first had to fix one parameter which
is we needed to take our model and for
our integrator slope of the tuning curve
there's a free parameter of how strongly
the inputs connect to the outputs that
was the parameter B in the previous
slide and we just set our model
prediction equal to the macaque
integrator slope of the firing rate as a
function of eye position however every
other point that you see in this graph
was emergent and what you see is that
the predictions from the model just
directly from the connectome match
incredibly well with the actual measured
sensitivities of neurons throughout the
oculomotor system to eye position in
green shown the goldfish and you can see
that in black the model predictions are
nearly exactly in agreement with the
goldfish which is the closest species to
the zebrafish that these were recorded
on but that there's also consistency
across the different species so I'm
going to leave that there and hand this
off to Emery to summarize what we
believe we've learned from this project
in its entirety and where we're going
next thank you Mark in summary what
we've shown you is a multi-faceted
approach where we've been able to use
large-scale imaging tools to
functionally identify key circuit
elements throughout the oculomotor
circuit to use a large-scale
connectomics approach to identify the
key connections key circuit interactions
between and within the elements
identified above and we've developed a
theoretical framework that ties together
functional and anatomical data to
develop a deeper mechanistic
understanding of how this neural system
functions we're also very interested in
the prospects of doing combined light
and electron microscopy where both
molecular and ultra structural integrity
are preserved and we think this kind of
approach example here being developed in
the Lichtman laboratory where they use
fragments of Intent robot like fragments
of antibodies called nano bodies or
intra bodies that are able to penetrate
through the tissue and allow for
preservation of ultra structural detail
provides the capacity to now at an
individual neuron level identified a
neurotransmitter class look at protein
distributions that will speak to the
neuronal excitability so together we
think this information will provide a
much richer dataset much deeper
understanding of the mechanisms
underlying circuit dynamics I'd like to
acknowledge the following individuals
from the laboratory and the funding
sources listed below thank you for your
time and we look forward to your
questions and comments thank you for
that outstanding presentation for
additional panels on the NIH brain
initiative a multidisciplinary approach
to neuroscience please view our agenda
on urban speech as a final reminder the
panelists will follow up with any
questions via email thank you again for
your participation